Hello folks,
we are live.
Today is release day
and man it is it is good to finally be
done with this thing.
Puffer lilib 3 is probably the hardest
that I have worked.
I mean 2 was tough but 3 0 was was
something else. Something else entirely.
And uh let's just let's take a second
here.
Take a look at this.
For thousands of Welcome to the boot
camp, not for humans, but for thousands
of AI agents. You're watching this in
real time at 60 frames per second. But
for the AI, it's moving millions of
times faster. On a single server, we
simulate over 3,500 years of gameplay
every day, more than the total estimated
training data of GPT4.
This is Puffer, an open- source project
built to train small superhuman models
using high performance simulation and
reinforcement learning. I'm very proud
of 20 plus environments from arcade
classics to board games, drone flying,
and autonomous driving. And the best
part, many of these can be trained in
just 30 seconds on your home computer.
Want to see it in action? Visit
puffer.ai to try it right in your
browser or download it for free.
so here's the plan today.
We're just going to fix any and all
small things that I've missed on this
release. I've already been shown a few.
I found a couple other myself. You
always find them on release day. It
happens. Um, but the fixes are going to
be quick here.
And uh, we're going to see what we can
uh what we can do about this,
how nice and stable we can get it today.
Then tomorrow we will start on new
things
assuming that there are not
all sorts of uh horrendous
horrendous bugs.
I have my chat open
because the other point of this is uh to
make sure
that
uh we don't miss any support messages.
Welcome Karthy. The release is live.
The release is live.
So I make sure I don't miss support
stuff. I do I do this thing where I pop
out the chat and I stick it under my
camera
So, I found this mess up right here.
This one's pretty small.
I don't believe I actually did the uh
the neural net for the grid policy.
Did I? Or is it just a No, it is just a
linear LSTM.
That should be fine.
10k a month.
Honestly, I should raise it.
All our code's free. You don't have to
pay me a scent.
The paid stuff is just for people who
specifically want my eyes on their
problem. They want us to make their RL
just fast and say the stuff is hard.
You know, I think it would be generous
to say that there are a double-digit
number of people in the world who
actually understand this stuff well.
And the proof of that is that I should
if this were well optimized, if this
field were like well optimized, I should
not be able to come in and make it a
thousand times faster like with any
amount of resources, let alone running
like a small open source thing.
There shouldn't be a factor of thousand
to optimize.
How many years did it take you to build
this?
If it I mean it depends if you count my
whole PhD
because my whole PhD was on neural MMO.
I did two years before that on neural
MMO and all the stuff that I learned in
that was essential to building puffer
lib. So, I mean, if you're going to
count all that, that's seven years plus
the last year and a half, like eight and
a half years.
Increase volume.
Really?
That's cuz I moved my microphone. One
second.
and I can also raise it. Yeah. So,
that better? That should be
That's like not any farther than I had
it before.
Unless OBS has messed something up on
me.
Make sure it's the same device.
How much did you put into this?
Okay. Is there a basic example of doing
full training using a basic vectorzed
end including neural net optimization
and applying RL? Yes, there is. There
are several and there's a tutorial on
the website as well. Uh the one thing is
I did forget to upload the one of the
assets for the target end. So, I'm doing
that now. But there is a full worked
tutorial on it. And uh here I'll show
you.
Uh let's go.h. So this is the full code
of the target environment. 230 lines
including rendering. It's all nicely
commented. It tells you exactly the
things that are required and the things
that like you can do whatever. And then
you can train this. Oops. Upper target.
It tells you all the files to uh that
are associated with a new end like this.
And see that this thing trains 3.5
million steps a second. It was 4.5
earlier before I started the stream cuz
that's on the same GPU.
And then you can eval. Now these
commands are it's not like we have
commands over 50 layers of garbage. Like
there is a train script. It's
pufferlib/puffrl.
It's about a thousand lines of code for
the whole algorithm and logging and
everything. It's just all flat. Uh and
that is what we run on this. Then if I
do puffer eval
Very cool. Thank you. Let me actually
just get this onto the um
the Pi Pi repo.
I think. Well, let's push it first.
It's uh apparently target is like taken
out of the
uh it's in the get ignore because it's
like the target for whatever.
That's what happened. That's silly.
And this is supposed to have weights. So
we'll do
if you were a beginner and building some
project, how would you advertise it?
to get users.
I don't really like the thing is I don't
do all that much on that side of things.
Frankly, it's kind of just I just post
technical content and I've been like
consistently posting technical content
in a niche area that I know a lot about
for the last year and a half and then
I've gotten like a decentish audience on
X out of that. Um, a lot harder if
you're a beginner, right?
You kind of just have to build something
really good and then show it off online
publicly and then oftentimes good things
get traction. It kind of depends how you
package it. It's tough. I'm not an
advertiser, right? I'm a I'm a
researcher
Let me go get the uh there's like this
annoying cache thing
resume scanner. I only gained 24. I
mean, yeah, because I mean, if you build
something which there are existing
things in and it's like a pretty niche
area and you don't have a platform to
tell people like I don't like what do
you expect, right? It's difficult.
Okay. So now we will actually have the
let me grab token.
Okay. So that is now fixed. We no longer
have tutorial broken on release day.
first project they built and completed,
which is great for learning. I'm not
trying to discourage you at all.
Absolutely build more stuff. But, you
know, getting building stuff that will
get users will take time, right?
It takes time to become a more
experienced dev. It takes time to like
think of like it takes time to get
experience building really cool stuff
and knowing what to build and how to
build everything, right?
Takes a lot of time.
It also really depends what you optimize
for as well, right? Let's
I mean,
89 within uh
less than an hour of release is not bad.
We'll see how this does.
I really do hope that this does quite
well. This has been a lot of work.
I don't know. I don't really want to go
down the route of like paying
less technical less technical and larger
influencers
to like look at a very technical
release thing, right? I got a nice
trailer cut together. Um,
and we've done a few things,
but that's about it.
I mean, we have all sorts of articles
lined up that we'll be releasing all
throughout the week as well.
I'm trying to think what other stuff I
I'm likely to need to fix. I technically
did forget to put the grid environment
on the website, didn't I? And that's
like a really cool environment. So, I
think we'll do that live and then
that'll show people the process of like
running a net and see.
Very cool MIT mug.
Oh, I have a way cooler one that's in
the dishwasher
that's just like the MIT logo is made
out of all equations.
Want me to PR Asteroids? Yeah, go ahead
and PR asteroids, but I'm going to fix
like a couple release things before I
get to it.
What's your like I have I mean we've
completed the release. We haven't like
completed reinforcement learning, right?
I'm here to solve the field.
Like when the we have this when the
field is solved, then I can go on to the
next thing.
Right? Now we fix the field. There's an
important distinction, right? So, by fix
the field, I mean it's no longer a
cursed buggy mess where basic things
don't make any sense. It's actually
pretty sane and consistent now. And that
took a lot of work. Uh it's not solved
in the sense that like there's a massive
gap between how good it is now and how
good I think it could be.
Agent doesn't learn anything.
Did you did you read the frame skip time
comment that I made? Did you understand
what I meant by that?
I will review it live then wouldn't I'll
take a look.
But let me uh let me do the grid port
real quick first.
How many more days until I'm paper
clips?
If I were to order the uh the AI CEOs in
likelihood of you becoming paper clips
if they solve AI first
I mean it's got to be like China at the
top right like whatever whoever does it
in China it's like either National Lab
or Bite Dancer, whatever.
And then, oh,
I don't know. Between Dario and Altman,
that's a tough call. You kind of just
flip a coin.
Ain't frame skip a rapper, though. Nope.
Read the breakout code or pong.
You don't have to do it as frame skip
either. Just one way of doing it.
Another way to do it is just to increase
the uh you basically just make the speed
of the agent configurable and then you
interpolate
uh you interpolate the movements in the
rendering. You can either frame skip or
you can do the opposite where you like
basically you upsample
uh you upsample the animations to smooth
them.
All right, let's actually write some
code here.
I need my my editor
What's wrong with China? Never got that
meme.
Uh, it's just that you kind of expect
them to like be solving AI in like the
quickest way possible with like zero
[ __ ] given about security or privacy or
anything else. It's basically the same
as like as it like what if the NSA were
the first ones to solve AI,
right? That's all it is.
Just go grab that plugin.
Then we will actually write some code
and I will show you how we uh how we
port
uh a model to run in C.
This is pretty cool.
Okay. So, what we have here is we're
going to use the breakout one as a
template because it's very very similar.
And what we have is it's set up uh we
have the C code set up such that you can
read in the weights with common layers
and even common predefined network
shapes
and then you can
where is it?
Uh, you can export those weights into C
and load them in. I think I said that
backwards. So, one more time, you have
your network in Torch. It's trained. You
export those weights to a binary file.
You load them into PRC. PRC runs a
network the exact same way as Torch
would.
What does it even mean to solve AI? Oh,
I got you, man. I got you 100% right
there. Hang on.
I literally wrote this article just so I
just so I wouldn't have to answer this
exact question repeatedly.
There you go. I'm only half joking.
That article didn't do super well, but I
kind of like it.
And then the ob size is 2 * vision
range. So this is going to be 121.
Okay. So, here we're exporting the
pre-trained weights. This is the number
of weights that we need.
And then what we're going to do,
we're going to make a folder for uh this
new grid. this grid environment and then
we will copy
that into there. And now we're going to
be able to load it from C. Created the
PR. I got to go study. Yeah, best of
luck with that. Either later today or
tomorrow or anytime this week pretty
much. I just realized that I forgot to
put the grid environment on the website.
Actually, I want to do that real quick
cuz it's a cool environment.
I will show how this uh this logic
actually works. Let me just get the uh
the boiler plate into place first, which
is where the model actually
or where we put the model in, which is
we actually just do it like this.
one agent.
I don't know the D type of observations.
Ah, it's unsigned char. So, we actually
have to copy it. See, good thing I kept
I uh I caught that.
So there is a thing where you can just
use the observations directly. I think
it messes up if you don't copy them over
though because of the dtype.
Then I will explain in a second how this
works.
Okay.
Does this work?
Cool.
So, we'll have to figure out why this
doesn't actually work here.
Oh, cuz actions is a float.
Whoops.
Apparently, I convert this from a I
convert this to not a float somehow.
So I'm just mucking something up with
the data, I'm sure.
So what is supposed to happen here,
right, is that you have this little
linear layer LSTM plus LSTM network
that's been trained super fast in
PyTorch. And then I have this uh very
small lightweight version
uh of essentially PyTorch inference only
but it defines the exact same layers
that work the exact same way. We
maintain this as part of puffer lib and
you have this like very simple way to
just load in common network types using
it.
Now somehow I think that the data is
getting mixed up somewhere. There.
Okay. Except the network is supposed to
be here.
Yeah. So, this is how it's supposed to
look.
Let me make sure this is the right
vision range.
Yeah. So, there's nothing set for the uh
the vision range here at all.
gets cold in reset and it gets cold in
step.
Yeah, it's not matching at all. Is it
actually a linear LSTM?
Oh, I know what's wrong. I'm dumb.
Yeah, I know what's wrong.
Hey Doctor.
Perf depends heavily on tape size.
You're giving it as the observation. Is
that not expected?
OBS Windows 16.
Are you having to zero it every step or
something?
I can take a look at it.
Is the algorithm not supposed to be like
quadratic in tape size or something?
Yeah, but like I don't know the end
dynamics enough, right?
Oh, when you say PF, do you mean how
fast it runs or how well the agent does?
There we go.
How well it does. Ah, okay. So, I mean,
it's probably just cuz it's randomly
sampling actions at the start and it can
get stuck.
It's kind of funny that it does this. I
presume this is like nans or something
that happens. There's probably some
instability with it.
purpose 1 mil.
It's decent.
I forget anything else or is that just
like the stability that I have with the
current version?
Oh, get stuck in the exact same spot.
And you can tell it's some state thing
as well.
amount of exploration is exponential.
Yeah, that's probably it. So, I mean, if
you know the problem doesn't take very
long to solve, you can stop execution
early.
That's a good trick.
You know, I've seen this happen before
in the actual end as well.
I wonder if we're actually hitting a a
fault of some type
here. We'll see if we hit a fault. Now,
we do not had any fault. So, I mean,
this says it's not some memory
corruption.
I've seen this happen in the actual eval
as well, though it's a lot less common
than I just saw.
To be fair, it is kind of janky the way
we're doing the policy.
policy recurrent.
Yeah, I don't think I missed anything.
[Music]
I guess we need the randomness of the
sampling, huh? But the thing is like I
don't Do I believe that? Because if it
were just the randomness of the
sampling, right, I'd be able to like
like I can move it here and like it
should recover.
I mean, I guess it it kind of does.
Oh, yeah, it does.
Okay. So, it's relying on the randomness
of the policy. That's what it is. So, we
need to add the randomness back in.
Oh no, but it is random here, isn't it?
It's not discreet. It's not a a fixed
sample. It is actually a random sample.
Ah, I mean, the fact that this doesn't
work tells you something's totally
wrong.
Oh, cuz it we just set it to true.
That's fine then.
Maybe this explains why we don't have
perfect maze solving agents.
What's your favorite video game and
would it make a good environment? Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I already
did my PhD on that one.
It's Runescape and uh yes, it would make
a very good environment. That's the
point of a lot of my research. We use a
lot of things directly from that and
from the insights of how that game is
put together and how you can write games
to run really fast.
Uh I do not allow myself to play that
game anymore because it's like you may
as well just hand me straight heroin.
Like MMOs are literally heroin.
There's honestly not a single thing
that's ever gotten me as hooked as just
like damn good MMO gameplay.
push my re work to repo. Let me finish
debugging this one thing so I can get
this awesome maze environment on the
website and then absolutely
Okay, so it's spamming one,
which should not make it pass.
I see.
It's just spamming forward into a wall
basically
you watch.
No.
I know most of the streamers though like
I like I followed at least like most of
that and I like I spent way too much
time on in that space but
we do actually directly use a lot of the
stuff from that in RL
like just like down like that game down
to how it works on a tick-bytick basis.
It actually tells us quite a bit
because basically if you just if you
take the game and you build it the same
way but you don't go like insane with
your code um it everything just runs
millions of steps per second.
Trying to think what I do about this.
It's just spamming forward.
or finesse anyone.
Uh, I was pretty mediocre at um
I'm trying to think what we do about
this. So, for some reason,
Let's just see what happens if we
epsilon gradient.
I mean, you would think something must
have gotten corrupted with the LSTM
state
Yeah, we can't upload this
unfortunately.
I don't want to spend forever looking
for this because I've seen it do this in
the Python as well.
So, we probably just need to redo the
actions a little bit.
Oh, did Impulse Wars not make it into
the trailer?
Oops.
I forget to send a clip. Oh, I did send
a clip.
All right, let's go look at some
contributions and stuff and then maybe
I'll mess with grid for a little bit.
We'll see.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing, Captain.
Yeah, my bad on the uh the trailer. I
actually, you can see right here I have
the clip. I sent this whole bunch of
clips and I guess I just didn't notice
what ones were used and what ones
weren't.
I had um
I literally had four different editors
make four different trailers. So, there
was a bunch of stuff and I guess I just
didn't like I missed it.
Yeah. Test. I'm I'm well aware of that.
Uh they were also very easy to PK which
was very Honey,
with the It's literally still happening.
Like
what's this benchmark folder? Oh, temp.
Okay.
Recursive.
I'm confused. Oh, it's in the get
ignore. That's fine.
Yeah, I'm looking at it, man. Right
here.
I opened two PRs. What?
Which one?
Wait. Puffer dot. Oh, okay.
I see
you want that one more. Okay. You want
that one done first.
Okay, you added credentials which is
good. You add yourself to the uh the
main page.
Let me add you there and then we'll get
you on.
Oh, I guess I didn't. Are you not? Are
you not?
Yeah, you're not on the main page.
Uh, let me add you.
And what was it left?
Did I do it? I did that wrong, didn't I?
F E
B.
Wait, what?
F E.
There you go.
Will be on the website.
And then the other PR is something as
well.
Make sure you didn't change any change
anything weird.
Yeah, I can go in. I'm just making sure
nothing's screwed up.
That grid environment is actually going
to take more work.
I kind of don't want to mess with it and
mess up the uh the current dynamics just
to have it in C.
would look cool for the website, but
it's not going to make a huge difference
in the scheme of things having one end
missing
because it's like it's mostly a research
end, not like a it looks super cool N.
That was not the trailer that got used.
I will uh I will give shout outs to at
least two of the editors that who did
something reasonable.
drone also has new PR. Okay, let's see.
Let's take a look at that.
Why is it run Why is it rendering that
fast locally? It's only set to 60 fps.
looks fine in Eval, but looks fine in E.
How can it look fine in Eval?
Huh?
What
Is it supposed to be green on one side,
blue on the other?
Uh, it's cuz it has to show you what
direction
to go through them.
Okay.
So, there's a render glitch
Okay. So, there's a render glitch because this should not be happening
because this should not be happening
here. Yeah,
the speed is wrong. Like the drone
itself is too fast
What are max rings and max moves
supposed to be?
There we are. Yes. So, if you don't set
those, chaos ensues.
The heck? They should not be asking me
for credentials.
Okay, that should show up on the website
in a minute.
It takes uh GitHub a little bit just to
push a new
update even though it's like static.
What's the next plan for drone then?
Trying to think how we uh how do we turn
this into
I'm trying to think how we turn like get
from here to like champion drone racing,
right?
How do you generate where the rings are?
Are the rings random or is there some
pattern to them?
Uh, in order to get into a PhD, the best
thing to have done is to already have
done half of a PhD. So, I pretty much
did that
random for now. Cool. Yeah. So, the
thing I was thinking of, I don't know
how they actually set the courses.
Um,
I don't know if here I Let me show you
what I was thinking.
Let me get my coffee first and then
we'll talk about what we can do with
drones.
Bezier, your curves were fine. Yeah, so
that's what I was thinking.
Oh yeah. You probably can't even see
half of it anymore with the freaking
chair in the background. Yeah.
What do they use to generate racetracks?
Right.
And then you do the same thing like
height displaced as well
cuz it's a drone.
This is the uh release day. Fixing
things, merging things, and answering
questions on release.
I'll have a look around.
Yeah, I think we should be a like if we
get it to do a reasonable track. Now, I
actually don't know how well that fits
because if you look up like Champion,
like isn't this the tracks are kind of
crazy, right?
Ah, okay. So, you see how the um
like the borders of the targets are
specifically made for them to be easy to
track. So, it's just like some really
basic state estimation stuff.
And then uh neural nets
vio. Yeah. So it's not
we can totally do something like this
like this is just open CV running
basically
they actually tell you how they do their
physics as well
So, yeah, we could totally do something
like this, right?
Scanning technique
work with lidar camera. Do you need
lidar?
I don't think you need lidar.
I guess it kind of depends because like
they do they paint the targets to make
them easier to do perception on, right?
I think also like they've got to have an
order to the loops.
So, it'll probably be something like 10
hoops and like they're just in order in
the observations.
We only use LAR cuz iPhones have one.
Oh,
you probably don't want to stick an
iPhone on a drone. Okay.
But hey, look. I mean, it's on the
website at least.
Yeah, I would think probably some sort
of like
it definitely has to be like larger
scale, right? We'd want to see like a
larger area that it's flying over with
more hoops that are like connected in
some sort of sane way.
probably numbered as well
because it shouldn't just be observing
like all the hoops. It should also have
them in order, right?
Does it get penalized for hitting the uh
the rim at the moment?
All the groundwork should be there.
Yeah. I think the only thing that's
going to be tricky is figuring out how
to not spend forever on perception,
right? To run it on a real drone.
Yes, they collide. Okay, cool.
Yeah. Yeah, I mean, this is a pretty
darn solid start, Oh,
I wonder if there's some basic thing we
can do where like even before we deal
with the perception part,
can we just like see if this can fly a
drone from like point to point or stuff?
We rescan their route and do a three.
Oh, I see.
Not attached to the drone. I Okay, I
see.
We'll have to figure out what drones
would be like good to play with.
So, I mean, getting it working in the
real world for sure. And then the other
question I have is like what's like the
most agile form factor we could get for
a drone? Because even if it's something
that's incredibly difficult for a human
to fly, we can probably just do it with
RL easily, All right.
Opinions on Gflow networks.
No opinions.
I have not done
anything on that.
Carrot drones.
Okay.
Those
Okay, so they make these super high-end
things
which we could get.
They've discontinued all their consumer
drones as well.
Time to start a drone hardware company,
I guess.
favorite RL researchers beside myself.
Who the hell's even doing this stuff
anymore?
I mean, straight up, like all the ones
that I knew in RL left. Like, they all
got sick of dealing with it and left.
Like, there's some cool stuff at NYU.
There's some cool stuff in Jacob
Forers's lab. Uh, but there are very few
people left actually working on the core
research. And it shows, you know, like
the fact that there's been basically no
sustained progress since 2019 until
puffer
should kind of show you
like my answers would have been like
Costa or Chris Bamford when they were
doing RL
um or even briefly Clemens.
He did some cool entity based RL stuff,
but uh yeah, they don't do that anymore.
just refuse those cash credentials
today.
Only other thing I can think of is the
grid stuff. Otherwise, we start on meta.
We could start on meta.
I wish Keen actually did some cool
stuff.
I really don't know what they're doing
because
they're basically going polar opposite
of the direction I'm going in. And like
I don't think it's going to work out for
them.
I mean, the thing that they released
lately was cool, but it was literally a
meme um in like 2018. I guess they
wouldn't know this. Sutton should know
this. I know Cararmac wouldn't, but it
was literally a meme in 2018 like,
"Yeah, we're going to make a robot
control the joystick to play Atari."
Haha. Because it was like the slowest
thing you could possibly imagine, right?
Like, you don't even make the problem
really any more interesting. Like,
intellectually, you haven't made the
problem any more interesting at all.
You've just made it way slower. So, like
it's cool that you can get it to work,
but like you're just going to make
everything super slow.
All right, let's go check a look at
meta.
Here's what we're going to do.
I'm going to I'm going to sync this fork
now and then I'm not going to sync it
again
until we have it working because they
132 commits in the last week. Get out of
here.
Let me show off what this is actually
before we uh we just start working on it
so people can get an idea because I
promised these guys I would help them a
little bit on this once we have the
release done. Um so I think we're going
to just start on on that. So meta
is this pretty cool environment. It
looks like this.
It's kind of like a factory env in a
sense where like there are different
resources you have to collect and then
move them to different collectors and
converters and things. See you Sam.
So uh yeah, let's see what we can do
about this.
BD,
welcome
BDFX Pro.
Who's I'm here?
Oh, is that Mary?
Let me reply to that real quick.
How that end
UI?
Which UI?
This one or uh
where is it?
Or this one?
So, this is some crazy JavaScript thing.
I have no idea what this is. All of our
graphics that we have for RMS are made
with Rayb.
And I mean, you can see like they'll
look just as good.
Uh, does this not activate the
environment?
and my teammug.
I mean, I have several.
They kind of just give you a bunch of
mugs. So,
I have a bunch of mugs.
one suggestion for three docs. Yeah,
shoot.
So, literally none of their code works.
Typical.
Let me see what else we can do with
this.
We're going to have to get pretty deep
into their code to fix this, I'm sure.
like this is just it's a bunch of code
for this thing,
but we'll start on
I could make it more end to end. Yeah,
the thing is like
I mean it would be pretty easy to just
add the train commands and stuff in.
I would. Yeah, that probably makes
sense.
Help you to make it.
If you said emit like a reasonable PR
draft of it, then sure. I don't want to
make the docks like massively longer
than they are, though. I think it's just
like adding You'd pretty much just add
like a couple blocks for the train
commands.
I need to understand end to end.
Train and eval are like two lines.
Metrics are like another line.
what RL lib has right now.
Well, RLI is terrible, so I definitely
don't want it to look anything like
that.
Like, do they even have docks?
I think that they have like overbuilt as
hell docks, right?
Yeah, they have like massive amounts of
docks for like all their complicated as
hell [ __ ]
Like we're fundamentally not trying to
do this because we're not trying to
build something that's this bloody
heavy.
Yeah, Ray Core is super simple.
Ray core is good. RL. No.
God, I don't think there's a single time
I've gone to use this environment that
hasn't given me a new error.
What are you facing is my question. Like
instead of giving me instead of saying
oh this is how the doc should be like
can you tell me what is like what is the
thing that you're running into that is
confusing to you
like if you treat this like rlib and
you're expecting like something like
rlib gives you you're just going to have
a bad time because it's not rlib. But
like the thing that you need is not like
an RLIB style tutorial. It's like it's
to not treat this like RLIB because it's
completely different. Like the core
design philosophies are basically
diametrically opposed.
Like you pretty much can't find a
farther apart library than RLIB from
what we built.
The point is not like RL lib but good,
right? It's like
it's more like clean RL but faster and
flexible. Not RLI but good.
I mean, we have examples. This is
already more overbuilt than something
that we need, though. There's literally
not this much stuff in Puffer Lib that
you need to do.
Like we've had stuff like this before
and it was a pain in the ass to maintain
it and like nobody really liked it
either.
Like we have them all in pure code here.
Like turning these into like turning
these into mini blog posts each does not
sound particularly fun.
So I' I'd rather you tell me like where
you're confused about stuff rather than
saying can we build something like this
because like I kind of hate this
frankly.
So like I will absolutely make stuff
easier, right? And I will like listen to
like, hey, this was difficult for me to
understand how to do this or like I
couldn't find information about this,
but I'm not necessarily going to put it
in the format that you're thinking of,
right?
share that on Discord. Yeah, just like
tell me like what if you just like will
write like what are the things that like
you feel like don't make sense or things
that you would like to have explained
better or like information that you
can't find then I can do something with
that. If you say like, "Hey, can we make
something that looks like Stripe docs or
looks like these other docs?"
It's going to be like, "Well, the thing
that you're trying to learn doesn't lend
itself to that format, right?
So, I'm not going to be able to do very
much.
I forget who the heck it was that I got
that from. It was like I don't know
whose like talk it was originally who
said this,
but like since I've started asking that,
I've gotten like way better feedback
from users because like telling me, "Oh,
it should just be done this way." It's
like
one, you're not even going to like the
result, and two, you're going to cause
me like a ludicrous numbers of hours of
hellish debugging and work and
maintenance, right, if I do it that way.
But if but the thing is the thing that
you the thing is like there usually is a
problem that can be fixed when people
have like hey can you do this?
So if I understand that then I can go
somewhere with it
Okay, so they for some reason they just
took rewards out of here completely.
Every feature needs to have proper
Yeah, I don't do that either because
think about what that does, right? If I
give you a procedure to follow,
I mean, maybe it makes it easier to
review stuff, maybe it makes stuff
higher quality, maybe it doesn't, but
what it definitely does is it g it gives
people more work who want to contribute
and doesn't even necessarily save me any
time.
So in general like I will only put a
procedure in place if it really really
really obviously helps something right
otherwise I tend to go to like zero
procedures.
You don't even have to like raise an
issue on GitHub in order to get
something fixed. You can come here and
tell me. You can just write something on
the discord. You know there are million
ways you can do stuff like to either
contribute to the project or report
errors. I try to make minimal minimal
minimal friction on everything.
I mean, it seems to me that like you're
pulling in a lot of things from like the
way that big tech builds stuff and it's
just like we don't build stuff that way
and it's intentional.
I don't do everything by myself though,
right? I have all these contributors and
the thing is I have more contributors
than I would have if I had those
procedures in place.
That's the key.
I have more contributors than I would
had if I have a if I had a bunch of
procedures.
And the procedures, honestly, they don't
even save you any time.
This is not a puffer lib environment
here. Right here, this is not a this is
not a puffer end. This is a third party
environment and they're going to build
their stuff the way that they're going
to build it. I support their work, but
this is not part of Puffer Lib.
This is this is not a backwards compat.
This is not a puffer lib issue
whatsoever.
This is a like this is a their codebase
issue.
which like the reason I'm doing this now
is because I said that I would and it's
been several months and like I've been
waiting for them to make it sane and
stable and it's just not. So if I'm
going to fix it, I'm going to just have
to fix it in the current state that it
is.
And if I'm able to do it, then they'll
be very happy about it.
But I do owe them some work. So
So, for some reason it looks to me like
they just this puffer end is just not
tested
because
Oh
yeah, I see what they did.
Ah, that's annoying.
It's probably like this or something,
right?
have rewards.
It doesn't.
Okay, so presumably
this works and the uh number of channels
changed.
I go find they I think that they will
have told me
I think I just have to put this into the
network. I mean, this is kind of
ridiculous that they did it this way.
Yeah, I don't I just don't know why they
would do this. This is insane.
finish frame skip code. I read the frame
skip code in breakout.
Yeah.
Yep. That's all it does now. You got two
options, right? And it just depends on
how accurate the physics of the game
need to be.
You can make the ship move farther every
frame, basically.
So, let's say that you were to make the
game designed for like you designed the
game to run at like 10 FPS max, like 5
to 10 FPS. Okay? So, every action moves
the ship pretty far. and then you just
smooth in animations when you actually
render the game. That's one way to do
it. The other way is to just do frame
skip. Probably with Asteroids, it'll be
fast enough to just do frame skip and
match the other arcade MS. So that's
probably what I would do.
We do it the other way around for like
the really complex M like neural MMO 3
for instance. It's generating and
rendering 12 frames for every step. So
that it's actually running very like
it's only running a few steps
for per unit time, but you actually see
everything animation smoothed.
That comes from MMOs as well cuz MMOs do
that.
Okay. So, now you actually have to one
hot it, right?
Do you oneh hot it or what?
I actually kind of forget.
Where did all the channels go?
Ah,
I see.
So what is this num layers thing
supposed to do actually?
Wait,
batch indices.
Yeah.
Um I
did they actually do it this way.
I mean, that's not going to train at
all.
So, I guess what we're going to have to
do,
we're have to figure out their
observation structure.
We're going to There's no getting away
from getting into the uh the C++ mess.
They've made such a mess of this. Like,
I don't know how the hell I'm supposed
to
do this.
added frame skip to PR.
Thank you.
Uh I can review it at some point soon.
Asterids will be a very nice imp to have
for sure.
Here.
You want me to go through it now?
I can do that.
Okay. We'll give you some feedback on
things. This isn't too bad.
This this
like this
Action space is four
probably.
Hey, bet. I got a little bit of RNR in.
I'm still pretty burnt, but uh we're at
least getting the release done.
We're starting on some other stuff.
Of course, the second I come back,
there's like crazy [ __ ] to deal with.
Not this. This code's totally fine, by
the way. Um, I'm I actually would like
to know what this is. Oh, it's just at
the edge of the screen. That's fine.
Trailer turned out good. I think it was
pretty good. Yeah.
Yeah, it was crazy client stuff. I mean,
the thing with that guy's list is half
of it was like him just having outdated
code from 20. Um,
and there are like a few things I got to
do in there.
Yeah, I got I figured that out. Wouldn't
that's fine.
Okay. So, it's just a radius collision,
right? That's cool.
Technically,
technically you don't even need to do
the shape of the asteroids
during the sim. You only need the shapes
at render time. But as long as it's fast
enough, it doesn't matter.
They're only calculated at render.
Really?
Oh, well done then. It'll mess up your
memory a little bit, but not that bad.
If that's how you did it, then good job.
That's like quite a good level of
insight
to uh to do that.
from the engine and renderer.
Yep.
Okay. So, you did a relative position
divided by size. So, that's good.
Velocity is not normalized, but
depending what the range is, that might
not be a big deal.
Okay. So, the only thing I'll actually
let me finish this and then I'll tell
you the thing that I think you missed.
You normalized in the engine. All right.
That's fine. Then
wait, what the heck does this get? Time
of day.
Why would you not just do that in terms
of ticks?
Yeah, dude. Just make that. Yeah, that's
like way more complicated and probably
slower than it needs to be. Just
you can shoot every n frames,
right?
Yeah.
So, that's a little silly.
Yeah,
that's okay.
It happens.
And also is this is totally going to
mess you up anyways because this is
literally
Yeah, this is in real time.
So it can't shoot at all because of how
fast this env is running.
There you go.
I just realized it's like doubly screwed
up.
Oh my god. I don't know why you do that.
That's funny.
Yeah. Don't ever do that. Don't ever
depend on the real time for anything.
You always do stuff in frames.
I'm tempted to make the ship the puffer,
but whatever. We'll leave it as is for
now.
We'll consider that.
All right. So, the other piece of
feedback I have for you, so fix the time
thing and see if it trains. And if not,
okay,
the fact that you've done this relative
is correct, the normalization of
correct, and the information that you've
included here is correct.
Do you see what is wrong with the
observations?
No.
All the data that you have in this array
is correct. I'm going to give you a
minute to think about that and I'm going
to use a restroom. I'll be back in a
second.
Not the velocity. I'll be right back.
Okay. Have you figured it out?
Ding, ding, ding. Correct.
Sort the asteroids.
Size of the asteroid would be a good
idea as well, but I actually missed
that.
So, yes, it does need the size. I didn't
even realize that that was missing. Sort
the sort the positions.
Do you understand why?
Like, do you understand why
architecturally you need to do that?
Okay, we're going to explain a thing
real quick. This is useful for folks
watching.
Okay. So here this is why
this is why you have to sort
observations of points and distances.
So this is a neural net. This is going
to map this input vector to some latent
state. It is going to do this
via a matrix multiplication. Right? So
this is actually going to be a layer.
a layer that is a big block of weights.
It's probably going to upsample it even,
maybe down sample, depends. Let's say
it's it looks something like this,
right? This is usually how you draw
layers. And then you get Whoops, that's
a terrible line.
Not much better.
Okay, so this is linear.
Okay, but this is a matrix. This is made
up of weights.
And the problem with what you've just
done
is that this matrix has to learn
essentially a mapping of this coordinate
here
to all the different spots in the hidden
and of this coordinate
to all the different spots.
Okay? And then guess what happens?
Even though you would like this to be,
let's not use that color. Uh, let's not
use RG color blindness either. Try this.
So,
even though you would like this to be
the exact same transformation
because realistically it should treat
all the points the same, it's not going
to do that because it's multiplying it
by separate weights.
Okay? So, you want it to learn the same
transformation, but it's not going to do
that.
So architecturally you're kind of
screwed from this. But if you sort them
at the very least you are always going
to apply the same transformation to the
closest point and then this another
transformation to the second closest
point. And by the end here it probably
doesn't even know what to do. But at the
very least for the first few points
you're going to get something
reasonable.
It's not that like it needs to resemble
the same thing every time either because
technically look if I were to just
reshape this data. This is how I could
do it, right? If I were to just take
this data
and instead of doing this I do this.
Oops.
one.
Okay. So, if I were to do this and now
this goes into your big matrix
multiplication.
This is fine. Oops. This is 100% fine.
Do you see why? Because this
transformation, it's like a 2 by n
matrix and it's going to apply the exact
same learn transformation to every
point. So it's a point encoder, which is
what you want, right? You want it to
actually like to make the same decision
about every point
and to just learn a general a general
principle.
The problem with this type of
architecture
is that this doesn't give you a single
vector. This actually gives you one
vector for each point.
Okay. And then you have to take like a
max or a sum of these usually like a
max.
Now it's not slow because in theory it's
a lot of computation. It's slow because
of a detail of the way that this is
implemented in PyTorch or in most
learning libraries. I actually have a
plan to make this operation fast. So in
the future, it's possible that we can do
this type of stuff, but I have to write
some CUDA kernels for that. So for now,
this is a really cheap and easy thing to
do.
Yeah, I bet you're going to have to
scroll back like 5 minutes
because this is this is very important
to understand.
And if you understand this, this is
called what I have just drawn for you.
This here this is called entity
And if I were to give you an analog to
this, right? The analog to this if you
have an image.
We'll put like a little conf like this
that goes on this patch and then the
same exact com is going to go on this
patch, etc., etc. Why do we do that? Why
don't we just unravel it and put it into
a linear layer? You can do it. You can
write out the operation.
The reason we don't do this is because
we want to learn the same operation at
every patch because patches of pixels
look the same anywhere. It doesn't
matter if a patch of pixels in the top
left or in the middle or the bottom
right.
It's the exact same concept but applied
to entities where entities are just
collections of uh collections of self-
similar data.
So now you've gotten your money's worth
on um on this environment. So make those
two make the first modification that you
did uh which is like the time thing.
Make sure it actually works. See if it
trains. If it doesn't, do this. If it
does train, but not super well, do this
anyways and see if it makes a
difference.
And also to the folks watching, if you
haven't starred puff or lib on GitHub
yet, feed the puffer a star. Helps us
out a lot. It's free.
How long will you be here today?
Maybe another hour and a halfish.
Eastern.
I'm usually on a little after 5. I
usually end uh a bit before 600. 6 or a
little bit before.
I also stream all day most Saturdays. I
took last Saturday off because I was
super burned out from release.
Now we got to figure out this crazy
environment. Rockville and Maryland. Oh,
cool. I am also in Maryland. I'm on a
farm in the middle of nowhere
of your lab. Thank you. It's a pretty
cool space. I got to do some maintenance
on all these servers cuz they're all
clacking. They all need fans replaced.
And I got to also like screw together
the tiny boxes again. But they work.
Okay.
What do we do about this mess is my
question.
What's the best way to handle continuous
environment? There's nothing special you
have to do.
Nothing special at all. Same way as
everything else. You change the action
type. Uh if the actions are continuous,
that's it.
Oh, actually I'm getting a reply on
this. Cool.
How do you feed observation spaces? We
have several environments with
continuous observation spaces. It's just
a box. You feed it into a linear layer
or if it's 2D data into a conf. Works
fine.
Let's say data coming uses streams
very fast and you feed one item each
time.
Um,
so really high-res temporal data is
generally not a fun thing to deal with,
but it kind of depends what you mean by
that, right? So like you can subsample
it if you're dealing with like a game.
Um, if you're dealing with like a
control sim, you can still subsample it
pretty often times. Um,
and then if you can't, uh, an LSTM will
get you a decent chunk of the way there.
But if it's like a really really high
res and you care about really long
horizons, say like over a thousand
steps, then you have to start getting
fancy.
Replay buffer, that doesn't help you.
Yeah, that doesn't help you. Replay
buffer is independent of that.
and you I need to see your specific
problem as the thing because like
technically what you're describing could
be said of a lot of problems where in
practice they just work
Anybody see anything I've done wrong in
this?
They're not supposed to have 255 as the
max here. Uh, and they we don't know
basically if I've screwed up or if
they've screwed up.
having a hard time dealing with sensor
data.
Generally, before you start messing with
anything algorithmically, you want to
throw it at Puffer Lib, get reasonable
observations and rewards, and run a
sweep. And then you want to think about
how hard your problem is compared to the
problems that we've solved without doing
anything fancy. And uh if your problem
is not sub substantially more
complicated than one of the problems
we've solved quite simply then probably
there's something wrong with the data.
That's like your good first sanity check
because we can solve a lot of problems
just out of the box nowadays.
data is LAR data. Ah then you actually
need point encoders.
So
you actually do need pointwise encoders.
So,
where is it?
I just drew it like a few I drew it
earlier.
Yeah, this thing.
So, if you scroll back in the stream
half hour or whatever to when this was
on the screen, I explain how to do like
point encoders. You need a point encoder
for LiDAR. You can't do this sorted
thing. There's no way around it. It's
going to be slower than our other
networks. you can still do it and you'll
still be able to train like potentially
several hundred thousand steps per
second.
And if you want it to be faster, you
either have to uh wait for me to write a
CUDA kernel or write your own CUDA
kernel.
No, you don't need to you don't need to
do CUDA. Like you can get the like
several hundredk step per second
version. You just can't get the ultra
fast version.
Yeah, your ship doesn't I mean well
first of all you're not actually going
to use that thing for training whatever
the thing is that you build. Uh I would
hope you can just be using that for
development like Mac chips for um
actually training neural nets is is
insane. You can use it for development
and like puffer is kind of fast enough
that you can use it for simple problems
but like you really want GPUs longer
term. If you want to solve harder
problems you want GPUs longer term.
Puffer optimized for metal. Nope. But uh
I mean puffer very fast, so
it'll probably be pretty decent just out
of the box anyways.
like our environments run fast and our
training is optimized for big batches
and it's very low overhead. So,
you'll probably lose some perf to the uh
advantage kernel if you don't have the
CUDA version, but there's still like a
pretty good C version that we ship.
Oh, I guess we don't need the permute
anymore, huh?
tried to train with frame skip. What
happened?
Is it a problem that SPS gets cut by
four?
Training steps per second gets cut by
four
or what?
Where's Sim?
No. uh training step per second should
not get cut by four.
So in the little dashboard, how much
time is spent on the end?
Yeah, but you shouldn't be limited by
the end. The M should be so fast, it
should be negligible.
Like breakout runs 100 million steps per
second or whatever. Yeah. So 71% means
the end is slow. You got to figure out
why the end is slow.
You don't have to do BVH collisions.
There's nothing wrong with the radius.
Like the radius formula should be fast.
So that's not the issue.
Every particle.
How many particles are there?
Yeah, dude. That's not going to be slow.
It's just not like I literally I did
this naively for uh like 512 ships or
whatever and I just did like the
quadratic check and it was still fast.
So there's no way that it's just like
that.
just run uh I mean in pure C just run
like a basic run like a basic G-pro on
it and just see where all your compute
is going
It's just a very basic profiler. It'll
give you like it'll tell you how much
time each function is taking.
Won't take you hardly any time to set
up. It's just like pure command line.
Very easy.
I do this once in a while when I have to
optimize C code.
not good with C. Your C is fine.
Your C code is fine. You're actually
you're doing a pretty good job of it.
Like you're keeping it very simple and
not trying to get too fancy, which is
pretty much most of the battle.
I have velocity.
Yeah, it's not that bad though. Bet
absolute.
He has relative cords already. He did it
reasonably
and I told him to sort.
Yeah.
I already told him that.
As much as I like being here, I'm not I
am looking forward to being able to run
in Palo Alto without getting literally
covered in freaking golf ball sliced bug
bite welts.
ridiculous.
I run for like
hour and 10 minutes and I'm literally
covered in welts. Yeah, I use bug spray
like the super toxic stuff like all over
my socks which is about the only way I
can put it.
I have like I have socks like freaking
I'm running in like knee high socks as
is so I don't get lime from all the damn
ticks.
Pain in the ass.
the horse flies. I mean, you don't you
don't want to put that stuff on your
skin directly.
Yeah, I think we'll do not cancer. Thank
you.
It still runs reasonably. I'd say pretty
reasonable.
Oh yeah, this this thing was molasses
slow.
I didn't write the end. You can't blame
me for that.
I mean, it's tough cuz like I look at
the code and it's like it's gotten to
the point where
I basically would have to rewrite the
whole thing to fix it.
Yeah, but they're not going to want me
to rewrite their whole codebase.
They like their like they like the way
that they have it.
Okay, it's back to learning something at
least.
Not too much I can do though with 40% M
time. Like it's not even worth running
this on the multiGPU box. I guess I can
profile their code for them. That's a
thing I could do.
Provided this gets like three or
whatever.
Oh yeah, this is it's like a quarter of
the speed that it should be. I'll be
right back. I'm going to use a restroom
and then was it 447? Yeah, we'll keep on
this for a bit.
So apparently they get uh the same score
in 15 billion steps.
So uh yeah, that's a thing.
Hey Ryan, thank you.
And thank you for the wreck for Outer
Wilds. That was a good bit of RNR
yesterday. I still have to finish the
thing.
Yeah.
No, I didn't finish it. Should I have
finished it in one day? Am I just an
idiot?
I don't know, man. I go back and forth
between like, you know, doing
ridiculously good stuff where it's like,
okay, that was pretty clever, and then
just like, huh, I can't solve basic
puzzles at all.
I got stuck on this dishonored, you
know, like the like so many people are
in a room, they're like one of them's
wearing this color, one of them is like
they're sitting there and such and like,
you know, try to figure out like who's
sitting where or whatever. Yeah, I got
stuck on one of those for two hours and
eventually gave up. Though to be fair, I
apparently the reason I got stuck was
because the [ __ ] question was written
weirdly
and it basically made an impossible
condition.
I took 25 hours and looked up one
solution.
I see.
I don't know. This game doesn't really
feel like a puzzle.
Stupid Riddle in Dishonored is a puzzle.
This doesn't really feel as much like a
puzzle.
It's kind of just like an exploration
game more than anything.
It does feel like the game misleads you
a bunch though. And I don't misleading
puzzles are obnoxious because it's like
I don't know if I can make progress on
this particular thing at this point in
time and such, right?
Like I think you can find stuff like
completely out of order.
I think it's very puzzly.
I got to one puzzle section
uh
that was like interesting but not
particularly difficult.
Like the it's like a perspective thing
that was like interesting but not
particularly difficult. Like honestly
the much more difficult thing is just
figuring out
is like just trying to basically guess
in what direction you're being pushed.
Right.
I think I figured out the like the
canonically first thing that you're
supposed to do though, but I think I've
gotten like one one actual piece of it.
Start seeing puzzles. I see. H
I have to solve it instead of
reinforcing it.
I don't know. I don't think I've gotten
stuck on a puzzle yet, per se.
There definitely things where I'm like,
"Okay, I went to the place. There's
nothing here." Um,
I don't know. I'll talk to you about it
once I finish the thing. I'm not putting
in 12-hour days every day this week. I'm
kind of burnt. So, I'm mostly going to
be doing some stuff on meta. I'm going
to be doing some post-release fixes as
are needed. Uh like answering support
stuff. And then also, you let me know on
net hack. Yeah, cuz we got to do that.
Yeah, there's going to be lots to do
though. I mean, the release is is a big
release.
Yeah, I saw you playing it. Finally beat
it. I didn't I figured it was endless.
Cool.
I uh I recently I downloaded Overwatch.
I played like two games. Was like, "All
right, I can't aim. I'm not going to
play enough of this for it to even be
fun." And I just like, you know, closed
it instantly.
That's not every FPS. There are
definitely ones where it's very easy to
aim.
Constant upkeep. Yeah,
I can't pay that at the moment, man.
It's like I can't I can't be doing that.
is like, eh,
it's like literally, okay, think about
this, Orion. There is way more upkeep on
like being decent at FPS at FPS games
than there is on staying jacked.
Just play Reaper or Reinhardt. Yeah, cuz
tracking fire strikes is definitely
super easy.
I mean, literally like this is this is
all I got to do to keep the deadlift.
I'll infer it was like six plates. Nah,
you get like 335 on it,
which I think is decent for doing for
just like lifting it cold, right?
The other day I had to move it. Like
there were some electricians here, so I
had to move it and I had I think 325 on
it. So, you know, I had to like pick the
thing up, turn it 90°, walk over the
step, and then put it down on the other
side,
which is like, you know, that's about
how light it has to be for you to be
able to do it cold safely.
I probably can't do four four plates at
the moment because I haven't done I
haven't lifted anything heavy in a
while, but it's probably not that far
off.
So, Ryan, uh, cardio takes a is a pain
in the ass to maintain. Strength and
muscle, not so much.
Cardio sucks. That I will give you.
cardio horrible
strength though. Strength and muscle
mass pretty easy.
I don't think you get limited by time as
much as cardio just sucks to do.
Cardio just beat you up a ton.
Yeah, cardio just beats the hell out of
you.
Done with job search. Getting back to
research and exercise.
Very good. I assume that means you have
some decision.
I'd be interested to hear about that.
Painful to start. Yeah. The main thing
is don't go ham on the don't go ham
lifting too heavy and getting yourself
hurt. I got to tell you, the injuries
just suck.
Joining Jeff's lab.
Yo, congrats, man.
Big congrats to you.
Then we definitely have all sorts of
cool research to collab on.
I don't know how much Jeff is still into
this stuff, but um for the record, I
think that actually artificial life,
like pure evolutionary a life stuff, we
could actually make it work now training
at 10 million steps per second.
So that's a thing that's on the books.
I actually know how to do it as well,
which is kind of cool. I also know how
to fix all the crazy cursed multi-agent
stuff that didn't work in 2018 and 2019.
So, there's lots of stuff we can do. And
given that you're uh you do a little bit
more well, I guess you said you want to
do more science side stuff, but the
edgeheavy stuff opens a lot of doors in
research these days.
Net hack stuff is also good. Just make
it fast, man. If we make if we just get
net hack fast, I think it's good. All
you need just make it fast and we'll be
good.
All right, I'm supposed to be doing a
thing. Hang on.
Has anybody started the puffer?
Please do star the puffer. I would like
to see a large uptick in stars from our
release. That would be very nice.
Net hack for this summer. I think if we
can get it like decently quick, then
you'll start to see results.
make number go down.
We make number go down very good. You
can look up George George's RL clip with
him like fighting RL demons and you can
see I fight those demons now. I don't
want to fight his hardware demons. He
can fight the hardware demons. I'll
fight the RL demons.
We had this whole like spat back and
forth with support on these tiny boxes
because I was so [ __ ] mad at the way
that they were like I couldn't get them
unassembled to m to maintain them and it
took me like two days but eventually it
was just it was a bad power cable. So I
had to replace a power cable and then
they worked
and took me two days replace a power
cable.
I was so [ __ ] mad over that. Oh my
god. I was like I was livid over that.
I was like, I'm done. I'm retiring to
the mountains in Siberia and hurting
goats. All right. I'm never touching
another computer. I was so mad. Yeah,
GPU is fine. It was just a cable.
my goal for the next six months, all
right, is to make Puffer is to grow
Puffer as a company
so we actually can support all this
research uh at larger scale and to not
deal with as much crazy [ __ ] which
I say as I'm dealing with crazy
[ __ ] but it's aspirational.
Where's this config thing that I was
thinking about?
So, the only thing I could think of
and that we got to try this before we
try anything else, right?
That's interesting.
We'll see whether that's just um the
initial stuff though.
It does help with logging frequency
though.
I'm actually a little suspicious of uh
the way those episodes are.
[Music]
How does desync episodes work?
I'm going to hop on a call with uh with
David in a bit about meta.
Hopefully, we get him some results by
then.
But yeah, the plan is to pretty much
just be streaming uh stuff all week and
we're going to be doing a few things on
meta this week. We're going to be doing
obviously any sort of fixes that we need
to make for post3 release, but then the
cool new stuff that we're going to be
starting on is going to be uh drone
stuff. So, we've got like this massive
uh battle environment with all the
drones, and I'm going to probably try to
get that into a state where you actually
have like coordinated team behavior and
such.
We have anybody yelling at me over
broken stuff in Puffer yet?
few follows
ending 9 to5.
I'm going to be here another 20 minutes
or so. So, you can get your RL questions
in.
Yeah. So, this is weird.
Let's
Maybe not.
Not super optimized to be fair.
Can we dispense with log only on
terminal?
What
we have um
the same as your purple line?
Yeah, it's just it's sampled at a
different frequency and I don't it's
also like there could be differences in
learning based on this. So I don't want
to like commit to this until I I know
it's decent.
We should probably also just run this
for longer, huh? See what it does.
I can set this up to run. Uh,
let me do that real quick.
while I can here.
for that.
All right. So
Huh?
Oh, that just went and got puffer lip 3,
which is kind of interesting.
since we do have a fair few folks
watching.
We did have our big release today
can support it for free or right here.
Star the puffer. You eat stars. In fact,
I tried to get people to star the puffer
so much that I even made a tutorial
environment about puffers eating stars.
I don't know what else I can do, but
there you go.
You can uh read through the docs and
literally build this environment.
What do you see?
What do you see for feature selection
Um,
I mean it depends on your problem
literally like all you really want to do
is just think about what information the
agent needs to solve the problem and
then normalize it reasonably. So like
you know distances are better off as
relative coordinates than absolute
coordinates.
Um you don't want things to have crazy
high magnitudes or crazy low magnitude
stuff like that.
driving me crazy.
We're going to have to do the uh put the
new container on this machine at some
point soon.
Okay. No CUDA GPUs are available.
Lovely.
Okay, five hour run.
We'll see how that goes.
In the meantime, let's figure out why
it's so damn slow.
I mean, that should be mostly
reasonable. No.
Oh, and that also includes resets. This
includes the resets.
I mean, that seems like it should be
fast enough over 16 cores completely.
Something is getting in the way of this.
Well, there's their uh
better result just off the analing
Right.
We do. So I said make
this gives us Meta puff.
So, how is that the case then? That uh
when I have 16 environments, it's super
slow.
Do I not have enough parkour or
something?
All right, I got to go, guys, because I
got to go chat with uh the author of
this thing. Um,
for folks watching, thanks for tuning in
on release day. Haven't really had any
crazy bug reports yet, so I guess things
are decent. I'd assume at least a few
people have tried to like download it
and stuff.
Uh, let me kill this so that this
doesn't lag the heck out of everything.
I will be back
maybe later tonight, but also I'm
probably going to take it a little easy
post release. Uh, definitely tomorrow
morning. Be working on this. We'll be
working on drone m. We'll be working on
all sorts of new and interesting
problems uh following release. So, if
you're interested in my work or if you
want to get involved, buffer.ai AI
the GitHub to help us out. It's free. It
really helps. Really does. Just do it.
Go click the button. And uh other than
that, you can join us on Discord or you
can follow me on X for more RL stuff.
We'll be posting articles there all
week. Some of which are not going on the
website, so you got to get them there.
Hh. All right. Thank you. Bye-bye.